- Mom.
Is my vagina supposed to do that?
("Tootie Fruity" by AudioNetwork)
- Mom.
- Mom?
- How do I make a dentist appointment?
- How do I thaw a chicken?
- Can you do it for me?
- What is my Social Security Number?
- How do you soften butter?
- Can I have your Netflix password?
Can I have your HBO Go password?
- Mom?
- How many stamps do I put on something?
- You can put Windex on wood, right?
- What would actually happen if I washed
whites and colors together?
- Is it Dad's birthday?
- How do you cook rice?
- Do I have credit?
Do you have credit?
Can I have some of your credit?
- Have I had a tetanus shot?
- How many minutes do you boil an egg for?
- Are you supposed to ride your bike
with or against traffic?
- When does mascara expire?
- How long is chicken good for?
- Well, how long does
cinnamon stay good for?
I donno, like four years?
- How do I wash something
that says "Dry clean only"?
No, I did not get red
wine on my shirt again.
- How do I un-sign up for a credit card?
- Do I have any allergies
I don't know about?
What about shellfish?
What about fish without shells?
- Can I use some of your airline miles?
- What is our family medical history?
- I thawed the chicken in the microwave
and then I ate it.
Am I gonna die?
- Hey mom, I had a question.
Why did I ever want to leave home?
God I miss you.
Like, you used to annoy
the (beep) out of me
when I was a teenager, but like,
I really miss you now.
I can't hear you!
I'm going through a tunnel!